hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and my dog is
a decorated war veteran is yours but
today we're here to discuss my personal
favorite hunt hunt character mr killer
zoldick as we are here to present 10 fun
facts about killer that you did not know
and if you did i don't care because
they're still gonna be fun and it's all
going to begin with a quick round of
kilauea or killuna a very simple
minigame the rules of which are as
follows you have been targeted by a
member of the zodiac family one of three
deadly assassins has been sent to kill
you until you die and it's going to be
your job to guess which one it is should
you guess incorrectly then your
postmortem punishment will be to
subscribe to the new order view thus
resulting in consistent injections of
hunter-based culture administered
directly into your youtube feed and if
you are correct then the assassin in
question will give you a delicious
chocolate prior to ending your time in
this world so which zeldik will it be a
b or the third one make your choice now
and we shall reveal the answer in three
two one and bam it was kaluto so very
much a kiluna but if you guessed
incorrectly then you know the thing to
do and please do say hi in the comments
below if you are a new member of the
association welcome but let's begin with
killer fun fact number the first which
is that he is a very special boy of
every zoldic family member kilauea for
uh well for some reason is the only one
who was never taught nina as a child
which is particularly odd because his
younger brother kalito was practically a
nan master by the age of 10 meanwhile
killua was only introduced to nen at the
age of 12 and not by his family in fact
he'd never even heard the word before
sure he'd experience various forms of
den like killemy's brainwashing but he
still had no idea exactly what it was
with that said a complete lack of
proficiency in the only power system
available in series did very little to
stop killer from developing his own
series of highly deadly techniques the
most obvious of which is the rhythm echo
which is a bit of a zeldik family staple
but in a more unique capacity killer
also somehow gained access to the
ability to morph his hands into claws
which theoretically could be use of nen
because we have seen similar effects
achieved via basic enhancement however
killer has been confirmed not to have
been an end user at all during the time
of the hunter exam and when i say
confirmed i mean that look it was stated
in a data book which take that for what
you will but it has led to a very
intriguing theory that kilwa may not be
completely human and that he may in fact
possess dna of a magical beast and as
for the technicalities of how such a
thing could happen look it's not
something i'd necessarily put past the
zoldicks maybe silva spliced his man
juice with some beast juice flung to the
wad inside the baby oven that is kikio
and nine months later bam you have a
freshly baked killer fully equipped with
some sort of feline based capabilities
it's either that or togashi hadn't
created an end during the hunter exam
which well come to think of it as
probably far more likely with that in
mind though we moved to kill a fun fact
number two which is that weirdly enough
he is the only licensed hunter in the
series who lacks a target which is
problematic because it immediately
breaks the very first hunt of bylaw
which is hunters must always be on the
hunt for something and this even applies
to rookie hunters gone was hunting his
father karapika was hunting the eyes of
his clan and laeria was hunting for some
sweet sweet dollar-y dues but killua for
the bulk of the series didn't have a
goal at all he was just sort of coasting
through life letting the waves of gone
guide him to wherever and i think that's
rather ironically reflected in the
results of the hunter exam kilauea being
the only one of the living final
contestants to fail the exam is quite
appropriate given that he was the only
one there without a purpose i mean even
illumi had a purpose he needed the
license to do a particular job or
perhaps even jobs plural the killer's
whole reasoning for taking the exam was
to have fun and fair enough he probably
would have passed if it wasn't for all
of the brainwashing shenanigans but it
still fits and you know what else fits
everything killer wears in the 2011
anime because that boy changes outfits a
lot i don't know where he gets these
clothes or even where he finds the time
for the sheer magnitude of shopping
involved but he certainly does make an
effort which is very contrary to his
manga counterpart who makes
significantly less effort in the manga
killer's sense of style is more akin to
gonz he changes outfits maybe once an
arc and it's always something plain and
practical so much so that it's very
difficult to tell if he's even changed
at all if you are not paying very close
attention and it's interesting because
it seems like such a such a superfluous
change but it is part of a much greater
shift for killer during the entirety of
the 2011 anime because killer fun fact
number four is that he was much much
much much and i mean much darker in the
manga during the dawn of hunter hunter
killua was presented as a character who
i would more closely compare to hisoka
than i would gone killua was a brutal
being who would kill or not kill
depending entirely on how he felt at the
time now to be fair a lot of this is
retained in the 2011 version just not
shown to us nearly as explicitly a great
example would be when killer ripped out
the heart of that guy jonas i think his
name was in the manga the reader is
subjected to a very raw experience of
seeing the heart as well as killer
proceeding to crush it mercilessly
however in the 2011 anime killer holds a
sack that resembles honestly it looks a
bit scrotum-like if you ask me but then
he returns the heart to the dying dude
guy which is similarly brutal in
psychological nature but one is
significantly more visceral and we can
see this difference quite clearly in
regards to his relationship with gone as
well in the manga killer is far less of
a light-hearted instant bff and much
more of a very driven rival at least
during the hunter exam anyway and in
fact a lot of killer's character really
does become portrayed as a bit of a less
horny hisoka is what i could sum him up
as and this continues throughout the
manga with killua's change being quite
slow however the anime enjoyed a suite
of options to speed this growth up one
of which was the aforementioned outfit
changes to lighten the character but
there were also all sorts of other
elements like giving him the comical
addiction to chocolate also in the end
the manga kind of retconned itself when
it was revealed that kilauea's initially
brutal persona was entirely the fault of
vilemi's brainwashing and that our young
kill boy had been a sweet lad on the
inside all along in reality though this
leads us quite nicely to our next fun
fact where we get to bring you hakusho
into the mix the original incarnation of
kilauea is quite blatantly based on the
archetype togashi created with the
character of hie specifically with
elements such as having both them gone
through a torturific childhood both
being remorseless killers and both have
a bias towards using sharp things to do
said killing and in fact both killua and
hie are the last members to join their
respective protagonistic quartets but
even though kilauea would go on to
evolve into his own character the
similarities to hie in no way stopped
there specifically in regards to their
abilities which are both elemental based
and the fact that they both have younger
sisters of whom they are extremely
protective in fact a huge part of here's
driving new hawk show was his journey to
find his sister and when it comes down
to it that was more or less killer's
slightly more convoluted journey as well
plus the most important similarity of
all which is that here was something of
a popularity demon comfortably winning
both official you heart show character
polls an achievement that kilauea would
go on to not only equal but surpass as
killua has won all three officially
conducted hunter hunter character polls
and the interesting thing is that fans
were asked why they love kilauea so much
and many of them responded by saying
that they wanted to adopt him as a
little brother but really it should be
no surprise that killwell landed in this
position after the four protagonists of
fontanta were modeled so strongly after
the quartet of yu hakusho in fact were
it not for leorio's fading relevance as
the series went on and when i say went
on i mean pretty much from the very
beginning everything would have played
out exactly the same in terms of polling
instead though fourth place in the hunt
hunter polls always changed having once
been held by hisoka another time by
crollow and in the final poll the fourth
place position was taken by kite but now
birthdays kilauea was born on the 7th of
july which seems like a rather
insignificant date to us uncultured
western swine however this happens to be
a day celebrating tanabata in japan also
known as the star festival this event is
designed to celebrate the meeting of the
deities orihime and hikoboshi two lover
type things who were separated across
the literal universe and only allowed to
meet on one day a year obviously being
the 7th of july and this is significant
because it ties into killua in a number
of different ways the story of orihime
and hikoboshi can be very easily applied
tequila's meeting with gon and the
rather intense friendship that would
develop before their ultimate separation
alternatively it could also apply to
alaka and killer's for separation either
way it wasn't just some randomly chosen
date unless you watch the 1999 anime
in which case it kind of was where for
some reason killer's birthday is
arbitrarily stated to be the 15th of
june a day when nothing particularly
special happens whatsoever but the 1999
anime makes a lot of a lot of weird
addendums to kilauea which is very much
our next fact 1999 kilowatt is weird so
one thing we've already experienced in
the fun facts about gone video is that
killua is something of an adult film
connoisseur by the very curious age of
12 killer had been in a lot of cheap
hotels which i don't know why for
reasons i suppose i mean kids go to
sleep somewhere but as such he is quite
familiar with the adult film menu and
even invited gone to watch one with him
on this one non-canon occasion however
this was but one of many changes and
some of killua's other interesting
hobbies during 1999 include drinking tea
hating red peppers being slapped by
seemingly every woman in the series not
knowing how to write properly and of
course kilauea enjoys exploring cockpits
which i'm sure is not a euphemism for
anything
other than dead but this killer seems so
full of interesting character choices
and like his fashion sense in the 2011
series i imagine that these quirks were
employed to make killer into a more fun
and identifiable character to very much
preempt where he would eventually end up
in the manga and make him less like a
less like a ruthless murderbot although
to be fair he does still seem like a bit
of a robot with some of his net
abilities specifically with godspeed
which is often misinterpreted as a
single ability but it is in fact two
which is twice as many as one the first
of which being whirlwind which
essentially allows killer to program his
aura to bypass his nervous system thus
allowing him to produce automatic
reactions to seemingly any stimuli at
shockingly high speeds in fact there are
only two characters in the series who
have been seen to surpass the speed of
whirlwind who would be netro and meruem
because even the chimera and royal guard
were outclassed by whirlwind in terms of
sheer speed alone it's quite comparative
to shao knox ultimate nen ability where
he ends up manipulating himself by
rather ironically losing all control
whereas the second application of god
speed is more of a 50 50 endeavor it
increases killer's response times but he
retains control of his actions thus
making him significantly slower overall
but still insanely quick compared to
your average net user or average than
average anybody really but to put that
speed into some tangible perspective
apparently killerwork can run at
approximately 240 kilometers per hour
and that is on unfavorable terrain which
actually makes him faster than the top
speed of most average cars which is
pretty wild for a lesser application
also wild is ireland hello ireland you
are home to killer fun fact number 10
which is that you contain a building
literally named killua castle and this
is one of the coolest things i've ever
discovered and it really makes me want
to visit ireland just to see this very
coincidentally named castle although i
should point out that the castle is in
the republic of ireland which is
different from northern ireland for
reasons that the irish don't
particularly like talking about so i
guess my message to northern ireland is
that look if you guys want to keep up
you should probably go ahead and create
a gone castle simply so that hunter
hunter fans have a reason to visit both
islands however you need no reason to
visit this next video because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there